so there is a really big report SL rumor
going around right now that Kevin fugy
might be thinking about leaving Marvel
Studios then heading over to Star Wars
which would most likely mean that he
would take the job of Kathleen Kennedy
which many Star Wars fans might welcome
a lot of people are talking about this
report right now and the reason we're
talking about this today is because we
actually talked about it on our podcast
a few times many months ago also if you
are not aware our podcast is on Apple
podcast and Spotify just search The
Cosmic Wonder podcast podcast is in the
title name but before this report came
out from an Insider we did talk about
this because this kind of seems like
something that Kevin fige might actually
do Kevin fige built the MCU he started
us off with Iron Man then he gave us the
Avengers Avengers Age of Ultron Infinity
war and then of course Avengers end game
one of the biggest movies of all time
before Avatar re-released it was the
biggest movie of all time gave us some
of the best movies period of all time
and now he's building something huge say
what you want about phase 4 and Phase 5
and how Marvel Studios is doing right
now what he's taking on is a really big
Endeavor to tackle the Multiverse the
Marvel Multiverse and bring it all
together for a giant Avengers movie is a
huge Endeavor and I think Kevin feige
can pull this off based off of what
we've heard so far and the report is
that Kevin is thinking about
leaving Marvel for Star Wars
specifically after Secret Wars so
basically Kevin fige would finish the
next Saga which right now is the
Multiverse Saga of the MCU and after his
huge film Avengers Secret Wars he would
leave he would go onto something new and
today we'll talk about if this could
actually happen this report is coming
from The Insider my time to shine hello
who stated in a tweet Kevin fige is
thinking about leaving Marvel after
Secret Wars and take over the Star Wars
franchise now one we already know that
Kevin fogy was and is as far as we know
going to make make a Star Wars film this
is confirmed Disney announced this Star
Wars announced this he's producing the
movie he's going to be working with
Kathleen Kennedy but this report is very
different this report says that he's
going to take over the Star Wars
franchise which means he would take over
Kathleen Kennedy's job now most Star
Wars fans haven't exactly been too
thrilled with Kathleen Kennedy over the
years and despite whatever you think
about the MCU right now we do know that
Kevin feige knows how to build a huge
connected Universe Kevin feige proved
what he is absolutely capable of with
Iron Man all the way to Avengers endgame
the entire Infinity Saga plus not to
mention he did this by working with John
F who plays a huge part with Disney and
lucasfilm and Star Wars so he would be
working with him essentially again to
build a huge Universe buil on what has
already been built in the past because
of course Star Wars is already a really
big universe and franchise one of the
biggest in the world but here's the
question would Kevin feige actually do
this now the report says Kevin feige is
thinking about leaving Marvel after
Secret Wars and take over Star Wars the
wording of this is kind of interesting
because my time to shine hello states
that he is thinking about it this
implies that an offer of some sort has
already been made that's what he is
thinking about because although Kevin
is huge he's a massive industry
person and does have a lot of power and
credentials behind his name if you just
wanted to take over Star Wars just by
saying it that doesn't really make it so
he can't just go to Disney and say hey
Marvel I want Star Wars now actually if
anybody had the best chance of going to
Disney and saying that and making it so
it would be Kevin feige but this does
imply that Disney has already talked to
him about it a lot of people have been
complaining about Star Wars lately and
Disney might be looking to Kevin fige to
kind of switch it up a bit for Star Wars
which means they would switch it up for
Marvel as well since Kevin foggy
wouldn't be there and what's interesting
is I would say John FAO could either go
to Marvel or Star Wars taking over a big
part of it if not the whole entire thing
for each franchise but again could this
actually happen the Tweet is worded in a
way that makes us believe that an offer
has been extended to Kevin fige or at
least a discussion has been had now
there's one singular argument for Kevin
fogy taking over Star Wars that could
actually go both ways it could either
tell us that he is indeed going to leave
Marvel and take over Star Wars or
there's no way he's going to do that at
least not for another 3 years or four
years or 5 years or so after Secret Wars
and it all comes down to the X-Men but
first big thank you to Highland titles
for sponsoring this video before we leap
back into the world of superpowers I've
got something truly extraordinary for
our Noble listeners imagine that you yes
you can become a lord or lady for just
$30 buying a plot of land from Highland
tile.com will allow you to make use of a
Scottish tradition in which land owners
are given a courtesy title with more
than 15,000 five-star reviews the
Highland titles gift pack is an
incredibly popular gift and the Highland
titles app available from the app and
play stores is a new addition that
allows you to explore a 3 3D replica of
the land choose the location of your
plot and decorate it using augmented
reality embrace the Majesty as every
purchase helps to conserve the a
inspiring heroic beauty of the Scottish
Wilderness you can soar into the world
of nobility My Friends by visiting
Highland ti.com and become a lord or
lady today use the discount code Cosmic
to receive 25% off your order that's
Highland ties.com and use code
Cosmic so this is why it comes down down
to the X-Men one Kevin fige is bringing
all of the Past X-Men into the Marvel
Cinematic Universe keep in mind Kevin
Figi worked on the very first X-Men film
as an associate producer and he pretty
much worked on about everything after
that X-Men 2 X-Men the Last Stand
Daredevil Hulk The Punisher of the
Spider-Man films I mean he was there for
it all and that's why he's kind of
perfect to make secret Wars because he
can bring all these variants all these
old characters that he worked with
before into the Marvel Cinematic
Universe and according to past reports
from insiders he is doing this for a
very specific reason one is to make it
to where these actors can say they were
actually a part of the Marvel Cinematic
Universe it didn't exist back then with
the X-Men and Spider-Man Etc and a lot
of the actors that Kevin fagy really
loves said that they wish they could
have been a part of something like the
MCU so this is his way of doing that
he's bringing those characters those
actors into the Marvel Cinematic
Universe but according to reports he's
doing this so he can say goodbye so we
can have have a proper sendoff of those
X-Men of the original ones that came
before we can say goodbye before the new
X-Men come in so this is where the X-Men
could either make Kevin fige stay or
make him leave he could say goodbye when
he says goodbye to those X-Men he could
say this is what I've done now I brought
all these people that I know and love
these characters that I know and love
into the Marvel Cinematic Universe I
made Avengers endgame I made Avengers
Secret Wars and now with the X-Men I am
saying goodbye myself and now I heading
over to Star Wars to start something new
to start the next chapter of my life
because we understand how that is he's
done this for so long perhaps he wants
something new however at the same time
the new X-Men are coming to the Marvel
Cinematic Universe and that is something
that I imagine he's going to want to be
a part of that's how he got his career
started with the first X-Men film and
now he is the president of Marvel
Studios and in charge of casting and
creating the story for new X-Men
characters not only that but inner
weaving the story of all of these X-Men
characters into the connected Marvel
Cinematic Universe that is huge and that
is something that could definitely keep
him around I can very much see him
staying specifically to make sure the
X-Men are handled appropriately and
let's face it we've heard a lot of tea
recently we've heard a lot about the
drama that's been going on over at
Marvel Studios recently but we've never
really heard that Kevin feige is fed up
with everything yes Marvel Studios has
had some misses recently but but let's
not forget about all the hits that
they've had as well plus they have
really big projects coming up like
Captain America Brave New World the
Daredevil series Deadpool 3 with Hugh
Jackman Loki is incredibly big right now
with the finale coming in only a few
days and of course the next two Avengers
films Avengers King Dynasty with the
Fantastic war in between and then
Avengers Secret Wars there's a lot of
really big things coming up that I'm
sure Kevin fige is really excited about
so right now could he be thinking about
leaving yes it could be a thought in the
back of his head because Disney could
have simply said hey if at any point you
want it you got Star Wars you can take
it over you can do your thing we trust
you I'm sure to some extent that
conversation has happened especially
since he's going to produce a Star Wars
film so that combined with Avengers
secret war is basically going to be a
soft reboot for the MCU and the next
phase basically almost going to be
starting from scratch Kevin fige could
decide that somebody knew might be best
for that I built my universe I built it
up from Iron Man to Avengers Secret Wars
and now it's kind kind of being reset so
now somebody new should take over a new
universe and I'll leave with pride
knowing what I have accomplished and
I'll go over to Star Wars and give it a
go we honestly don't really know if it's
going to happen or not like I stated it
could really go either way Kevin fig
could call it quits after Secret Wars or
decide that he wants to be a part of the
X-Men and the new universe after Secret
Wars what we do know is that clearly it
seems that if he wanted to take over
Star Wars the option for him to do so is
on the table will it happen well we'll
have to wait and see but let us know
your thoughts about this do you like
this do you not like this do you hate it
are you in love with it do you think he
would do really well over at Star Wars
do you think Star Wars would benefit
from this and do you think Marvel would
really suffer from this let us know your
thoughts down below don't forget to like
the video and subscribe of course to
stay up to date on the MCU and so you
can enter our giveaway for a chance to
win Xbox series X A PS5 some Marvel
Legends items or some DC items and
winner picks one item and we pick one
winner at the end of each month you have
to be subscribed and leave comments on
our videos you can find us on Instagram
and Twitter as well and as always thank
you all so much for watching woof
woof